es un excéntrico pionero de la
tecnología con barba de mago el sueño de
jacques delors y de iniciar una
conversación en los años 90 dio lugar a
una plataforma online y líder twitter
uno de los actos más recordados en su
papel como si joe ha sido el manejo de
los tuits deshonestos por ejemplo eligió
cerrar la cuenta de twitter del
expresidente donald trump después de la
irrupción en el capitolio actualizamos
nuestra política de integridad cívica
para abordar la información engañosa o
en disputa que socava la confianza en la
elección causa intimidación o supresión
de votantes o confusión sobre cómo votar
o tergiversa la afiliación o los
resultados de las elecciones los últimos
seis años no han sido fáciles parador si
con inversionistas que critican el lento
crecimiento de la empresa y dicen que le
falta concentración el por su parte no
ofreció razones específicas para
renunciar a parte de argumentar que la
compañía no debería seguir dependiendo
de sus fundadores así lo dijo en su
carta de renuncia que por supuesto
tuiteó si habla mucho sobre la importa
de que la empresa sea dirigida por sus
fundadores en última instancia creo que
eso es una limitación severa y un simple
punto de falla y trabajado duro para
asegurarme de que esta empresa pueda
separarse de sus fundadores dorsin
seguirá en la junta directiva de twitter
hasta que expire su mandato el próximo
año y seguirá siendo director ejecutivo
de la empresa de pagos square su
reemplazo será el ex director de
tecnología de twitter para agravó quien
tendrá que dejar de lado su experiencia
como técnico y lidiar con los problemas
sociales y políticos que enfrenta la red
social de casi 400 millones de usuarios